on est d'accord que la faut bouger ces
voix là on va bouger on va enfin bouger
allez hop c'est parti
on va bouger hop là whaou à l'ego là on
va descendre se faire un petit café
puisque est après tout on a le temps hop
là on va poser même la caméra
voilà comme ça on va donc prendre le
temps de se poser pour parler de cinq
erreurs que on va dire la quasi totalité
des débutants déjà fait même moi dedans
je me inclut donc un regard et le
jugement il ya voilà et puis on va juste
éviter de les refaire on va aller
chercher une tasse de café d'abord là
parce que oui j'ai totalement replonger
un jet j'échoue 1 je suis retombé dans
le café et tout ça on en parle
après un café et après l'intro
la et salut à tous les amis c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique mans
encore j'espère que vous allez bien ici
tout va bien ça tout se passe bien c'est
tranquille je suis ravi de vous
retrouver pour une nouvelle vidéo
d'ailleurs si vous atterrissez ici sur
cette chaîne pour la première fois bien
sachez qu'ici on va parler de caméras
appareils de tournage on va parler de
montage
bref tout ce qui est en lien avec la
vidéo ici c'est quelque chose qui vous
plaît vous pouvez envisager de vous
abonner d'attirer la cloche tout ça tout
ça
alors aujourd'hui je me suis dit que
j'aimerais vous donner quelques petits
conseils si vous débutez en vidéo si
vous démarrez un petit peu des conseils
sur des erreurs que j'ai faites moi un
comme je disais au début il ya vraiment
aucun jugement
je pense que tous les gens qui font de
la vidéo quand ils ont démarré ils ont
fait ces erreurs là ils ont fait
sûrement plein d'autres erreurs aussi
donc voilà les gens qui vous regardent
les petits bouts toise de haut en disant
ah tu fais comme ça mais c'est n'importe
quoi
dites-vous que aussi à un moment donné
il savait pas non plus et ils ont fait
de la merde quand on leur faire ça à ces
gens là si on n'explique pas aux gens eh
ben on n'y arrive pas et donc ces
erreurs là on va en parler
cinq erreurs qui sont faciles à éviter
et c'est à dire des conseils que je
donne
hyper souvent aux gens qu'ils m'envoient
leurs vidéos en dm sur un stade par
exemple qu'on demandait mon avis je leur
donne ses conseils là et vous allez voir
c'est pas grand chose au final c'est pas
d'aider des grands changements à faire
c'est des petites choses à garder en
tête et c'est facile à mettre en place
donc vous allez voir
rien de très compliqué uche là et on va
bouger un peu parce que là on a la
possibilité de bouger un petit peu donc
on va se mettre ailleurs à la up vient
ici toi là on a juste le cadre toujours
toujours c'est pas un conseil mais c'est
facile sur un conseil mais c'est un
conseil bonus voilà la première erreur
que je vois très très très souvent et
bien c'est une erreur qui est
compréhensible parce que vous allez voir
c'est lié à quelques petites abstention
qu'on peut avoir quand on débute c'est
de ne pas mettre assez d'humain dans vos
vidéos je vois énormément de vidéos de
voyages par exemple où on a des paysages
magnifiques des plans superbes avec
éventuellement même du trône enfin des
choses très très belle mais bizarrement
moi je décroche sur ce genre de vidéos
assez vite pour une raison très simple
c'est que ça manque d'humains les
paysages c'est très très chouette de
montres
des paysages c'est vraiment super
surtout sur les films de voyage moi
j'aime beaucoup ça j'adore en regarder
mais s'il n'ya pas d'humains film de
voyage ou n'importe quel film l'oeil du
spectateur s'il ne voit que des paysages
au bout d'un moment ils décrochent et
donc il faut garder en tête qu'il faudra
alors soit vous filmez vous soit filmé
un ami qui est avec vous des gens sur
place n'importe qui mais voilà deux
l'humain dedans pour faire vivre tout ça
le paysage seul c'est pas suffisant donc
pour agrémenter un petit peu votre film
n'oubliez jamais d'y incorporer deux
mois je me dis qu'on va bouger à chaque
conseil en fait on va aller dans un
endroit différent
c'est tellement grand il faut dire mon
palace que voilà où est ce qu'on
pourrait aller on pourrait ici on va
être à contre jour voyons où est-ce
qu'on pourrait se poser un petit peu
dans ceux d'andré cette immensité tiens
ben voyons on va essayer ici voyons là
la deuxième erreur qui est souvent
commise c'est de ne pas assez varié les
valeurs focale je vous explique en gros
ça veut dire que il va falloir faire au
maximum une alternance entre des plans
larges des plans serrés des plans moyens
pour amener du contraste visuel dans
cette vidéo pour amener un petit peu de
variété si on n'a que du plan large
c'est pas forcément évident de garder le
spectateur concentré si on a une
alternance ne plains serré de portraits
de paysages de choses comme ça
forcément on va avoir une meilleure
diversité on va avoir plus d'intérêt
suscité pour la vidéo c'est pas une
règle absolue on peut très bien shooté
avec une seule focale fixe mais il faut
penser à avoir du large et avoir dû
serrer de loin de près - mas faut
qu'elle préférait par exemple c'est le
35 mm ça m'est arrivé de tourner
uniquement au 35 mm parce qu'il y avait
des contraintes particulières
c'est complètement faisable c'est quand
même beaucoup plus difficile donc si
vous débutez n'hésitez pas à varier si
vous avez un zoom à faire du large à
faire du sert et en profiter pour donner
de la variété à vos plans au niveau des
faux culs retient pour ce conseil la up
on va se mettre ici et justement on va
jouer hop avec la focale clouque et je
vais me mettre très très loin toujours
pour illustrer un petit peu ce que je
disais juste avant j'ai profité 224 70
pour faire un zoom à 70 et variées
par conséquent un petit peu les valeurs
de plein la troisième erreur qu'on peut
très facilement faire quand on débute en
vidéo c'est de négliger le sont parce
qu'on pourrait se dire oui bah oui mais
je fais de la vidéo c'est l'image le son
c'est pas si grave si j'ai mon sens deux
boîtiers ça va suffire c'est pas
terrible mais bon l'important c'est des
images c'est totalement faux le son est
très très très important idéalement il
ya certaines vidéos des fois on peut
fermer les yeux et on est complètement
transporté par un discours par une
ambiance sonore part du sound design
[Musique]
il en est le terreau
[Applaudissements]
à
donc n'hésitez pas à investir dans un
petit micro il ya des choses qui sont
pas très très cher notamment chez road
qui fonctionne très très bien et ne vous
dites pas que parce que ben vous avez
l'image etc image est belle ça suffit il
faut aussi avoir du son de bonne qualité
parce que ben une belle vidéo avec un
son pourri c'est un petit peu je sais
pas moi comme comme un gâteau délicieux
avec un glaçage dégueulasse on n'a pas
envie d'aller chercher un petit peu plus
loin si le son est complètement je vais
très très vite être à court d'endroit
pour pour qu on se cale un volet - là ça
va pas être possible
la quatrième et avant-dernière erreurs
aussi que je vois très très très
régulièrement passer dans certaines
vidéos
elle se situe au niveau des transitions
alors bien sûr c'est très très important
les transitions c'est vraiment quelque
chose de primordial je parle pas
forcément de transition type gauche ou
des choses comme ça comme j'ai pu
montrer sur la chaîne mais la façon dont
on passe d'un plan à un autre elle a
énormément d'importance dans une vidéo
elle a autant de sens que l'image
elle-même ou que le son lui même ça
participe au storytelling c'est très
très important et toutes les transitions
notamment les transitions
logiciel qu'on rajoute avec des plugins
des vortex des machins des trucs comme
ça si on en met trop ça fait très très
amateur et si on en met quand y en a pas
besoin
ça fait encore plus amateur quand même
le mec qui a découvert movie maker et
puis bon qui bidouille avec ses textes
dégueulasse où ces transitions
dégueulasse moi ça me fait un petit peu
penser à ça à la limite vaut mieux
privilégier un cut simple une coupure
nette sans aucune transition a ajouté
que de mettre des transitions là où il
n'y en a pas besoin
faut vraiment vous dire que la
transition elle doit avoir autant de
sens que ce qui apparaît à l'image
s'il n'y a pas un sens particulier à
mettre la transition c'est peut-être que
le cut suffira amplement ou alors qu'il
faut anticiper au moment du tournage ce
qui est un peu plus compliqué les
transitions qu'on va faire et c'est
parti pour le dernier conseil voilà on y
va moi j'aime bien comme ça ça change un
petit peu on ne s'est pas tapé là voilà
où la fuite ou ça change un petit peu et
puis c'est moi c'est amusant je trouve
de faire un truc comme ça je sais pas
vous si vous voir ma gueule comme ça et
et mon immense palace encore une fois si
ça vous éclater mais moi j'aime bien
enfin le dernier conseil et qui est
selon moi le plus important de tous
c'est l'histoire c'est le storytelling
quand on fait de la vidéo on raconte
quelque chose on raconte une histoire
on va s'adresser à des humains on va
parler à quelqu'un c'est une forme de
langage se dire que on va le faire que
de la belle image s'est passé à côté de
quelque chose et c'est ce qui va faire
la différence entre une très bonne vidéo
et une bonne vidéo
ça va être l'histoire qui est racontée à
la limite il vaut mieux avoir une image
de moins bonne qualité mais une super
histoire qui laisse les gens en haleine
plutôt que d'avoir des plans magnifiques
tout du long mais qui génère pas
d'émotions c'est ce qui est très très
important à ce qui est primordial dans
la vidéo le but du jeu votre objectif ça
va être de générer une émotion en
racontant une histoire et de manière
générale en fait faire de la vidéo c'est
raconter des histoires c'est transmettre
un message faire passer quelque chose
que ce soit une pub que ce soit une
interview que ce soit un concert que ce
soit un film de mariage
toutes ces choses là c'est des histoires
qui sont racontées notre job en tant que
vidéaste et de restituer voire même de
créer de toutes pièces c'est le cas de
la fiction des histoires avant même
d'aller faire votre vidéo il faut pas
vous demander qu'est ce que je vais
filmer mais plutôt qu'est-ce que je vais
raconter
et voilà les amis j'espère que cette
vidéo vous aura plu cette vidéo bas un
petit peu pas comme d'habitude
voilà on a fait des choses différemment
et c'est bien de faire des choses un
petit peu différemment
de temps en temps si d'ailleurs cette
vidéo vous a plu vous pouvez bien
entendu mettre le coup de blaster sur le
pouce en l'air qui se situe juste en
dessous de cette vidéo vous pouvez la
partager pour vous abonner
si ce n'est pas déjà fait activer la
cloche tout ça me mettre dans les
commentaires ce que vous avez pensé de
ces dix conseils et puis si vous en avez
d'autres si vous voulez partager à la
communauté qui est de plus en plus
grande mais n'hésitez pas à les écrire
également que moi je vous dis à très
bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo on est
d'accord qu'un nom de dole et la barbe
ça va être un souci d'hectares
j'ai pas le skill taillage de barbe
donc voilà ça c'est des soucis pour
propos car sur vous les gens restez chez
vous et faites attention
et voilà a très vite